is now that a lot of guys are saying
that they want traditional women
traditional women traditional women and
then they don't value the money and
other stuff i've now come up with a
theory that the only reason why they
want these traditional women that do not
have money is so that they can have the
ability to leave these women at will and
have them destitute because especially
now with the whole texas band of the
abortion laws and stuff and seeing these
guys are just like cheering thank god we
can have you barefoot and pregnant back
in the kitchen and not working anymore
you know the craziest thing is
when the u.s planned parenthood is
literally a racist organization and it's
like you think that this is sex it's
like they i i just like why is that that
girl is married to in the bottom corner
i'm like that's your opinion of men they
want to leave you high and dry
she's married yeah on the bottom not not
the girl like the ones yeah i was
surprised at her coming yeah she's
married wow and even and even so implant
i don't know if you know about the like
roots of planned parenthood yeah and so
it's like it's like it's literally a
racist organization like so i don't know
why
like because they're both black so i'm
like shouldn't you be for these bands
they should they just don't get it do
they no they just prefer not to have any
children and let somebody else rule
their life and these people that want to
be independent can't be independent and
be running your own life with planned
parenthood in your life because you're
not independent then somebody else is
running your life for you or the
government like the government a lot of
women depend on the government with
their free programs and like they're not
saving women on two-thirds of the
consumer debt they're not saving for
retirement so don't spend money on a
rubbish
and the thing is is that now they're
blaming these um by now pay data you
know there's this big thing about oh
it's causing women to go into debt
nobody's making them shop and buying up
here later
you know even durian coverage when
i was it's not really surprising me
primark tick tock
i didn't know that was a thing what tick
tock primark the
cheap clothes okay and everybody the
women are going out there and they're
buying all this sheet for all these
sheet clothing
to show on tick-tock but where are you
going and you've got all these cheap
clothes
that not even oxfam would take anymore
because they're so cheap
and you're just going to keep on buying
and buying i've got i've got clothes on
when my son was yeah me too i have my i
have stuff from houston it's like when i
saw your mom's dress and i thought wow
she bought classic dress that she could
wear now this year next the year after
but half of these things that they were
disposable it's trendy and it goes in
and out and women just spend money like
what no that that's
the lady on the bottom right i was
surprised at her comment she sounded
like her head until she said that
yeah she
yeah she's she's got like i at first i
thought that that money thing didn't
really matter but i'm starting to
realize no these guys just want the
ability to leave you high and dry and
then laugh in your face
with your babies
you're gonna have to do something
exactly i thought my keys crossed my
eyes dotted
but that's like my own little uh um what
do you call it new thing that i'm just
like
what they really want i don't i don't
think so like because
i don't i don't think so i think like
like
like money just isn't like attractive to
them like they just don't like like when
we see an ambitious like driven man that
turns us on that does not turn a guy on
to like like i think they don't want
like a girl that's like bad with money i
think that's like a turn off i think
that like they don't want a girl that's
like
you know doesn't like is terrible
finances whatever but like i just don't
see guys like
being like oh my gosh that's so sexy
she's the ceo like the same way girls
are
like dad
ambition
i said the men that date me are
attracted to my ambition for sure yeah
because you're dating a guy with no
headboard
like but she's not even she looks like a
size 14 there yeah i bet she is she's
chunky yeah
she's scary she she's no she's demonic
look in her eyes like she looks
possessed like she's not right i've
rather than spend their money in the
dating coach she should be spending
money on the therapist yeah yeah she's
sure because she's got some serious
issues she's i don't know she's living
in fantasyland
i would have agreed with you paul until
watching that podcast that you were on
and all these women that they're pushing
these traditional values on that could
barely even formulate a
complete sentence and that's why i
wanted to do the reaction with you on
there because these other girls who are
normally on there but this is
entertainment
like it's entertainment
nobody sends them to come on the show no
people come on them and they talk
and they're like pushing the whole thing
that we don't care about this we don't
care about that meanwhile these are just
only fan girls that you're trying to
push these type of values on i'm like
this whole thing makes no sense
well well that's the problem with fresh
and fits they just bring on like the
trashiest girl and i said that on the
podcast i was like do you guys think
you're in like a little bit of a bubble
like i was like but i think that doesn't
they see women as though i don't think
they see women as like
actual functional human beings and this
is so running my own podcast this was
before
yes you are in a bubble and the girls
that come on are going to be trashier
because they make you more money but
it's indicative of society as a whole
so while maybe those girls are the
extremes i think there's a lot of
reasonable women out there but there's
still reasonable women that still have
sort of a modern mindset yes so it's
interesting like watching this back
because i would probably change my
answer now slightly
okay
hello hi
he was on earlier he said he wanted to
come back on
um
i
i totally disagree with the point of
um
what was it men
women
um
thinking that men
uh want women that um earn like a lot of
money or more money than
that's just simply not true you're hard
you're kind of low so can you say that
again
like more
i said
i said um men don't men don't value
women that make a lot of money that's
it's not really a turn on for us guys so
how much money do you make sir
got it
oh gosh
hello
maybe it's maybe it's my device let me
let me switch on to it see how rude that
is
that is so rude looks like she finds
them in maybe that's why they know that
she's easy i have never asked a guy how
much money he makes i have the only
reason i knew that x had that much money
was because he told me i never asked i
do not like i think that is so rude i
think the only reason why that's all
right i've only known how much
two one because i was a supervisor so i
knew how much she got paid and then
scott from scotland because we were
talking about it because we had the both
same positions
but because he was in scotland and i was
in london i earned more in the same
position so that's how come i knew
because we were studying together and we
had to it was one of those topics that
came up but i don't know how much my
mind earns it's doing my business yeah
it's rude you don't know how much you
don't know how much i earn oh it doesn't
maybe that's a leading question hello
pleased to meet you how much do you earn
should i make the man run away
[Music]
no i think
men that make like 50 000 a year are
going to be the ones that say oh we
don't care about how much money the
woman makes
okay
you know
it knows really really sad with all her
high classness so she's wearing around
her neck it's not a proper lady scarf
you know women wear scarves around there
now and and i know what she's trying to
do i don't know she dresses trash yeah
i've seen that's not classy no nothing
she's got on you've got all the extra
armpits can you see underneath here all
the boobies are spilling out all the
extra armpits and it's like what what is
your dating coach teaching you not to
dress properly
i think people talking about my theory
about um i don't believe that because i
just think they want to be able to be
the bread runners to leave these women
destitute and begging because after the
whole thing um only fan thing see i've
learned so much better how to handle
these type of girls so i kind of hate
watching it back because i'm like i
would say so much more now than i did
that's what she did i was watching that
one that i was on i just thought why
didn't you say this i should have said
that
so many guys are so excited i can't wait
till these women fail in the nation
because now i would say why is that your
opinion on men why do you feel that
strong like like that that says more
about you and it doesn't matter they've
done them what what what has what has
men done them men must have done them
something for them to hate them so much
they've got us have hang-ups yeah but
like that's your own fault and then it's
not i would say nobody can treat you bad
you will have people thank you yeah yeah
it's like nobody can talk to me horrible
down the phone because the power's in my
hand the red button that's
accountability so everybody's blaming
everybody but